[Musique]
maman va garder la petite ce soir ça on
pourra lui aussi en fait pas je serai là
à 18h bien mon coeur fait qu'elle n'a
pas vous avez des pousses de rené
gonzalez
nous sommes du ministère de l'intérieur
il a trahi la nation
il a volé un avion il est passé sous nos
radars et atterrit sur une base
militaire à miami avec d'autres du bain
on vient de fonder une organisation
qu'on appelle frère du sauvetage on doit
engager des pilotes à bordures
il est important que vous sachiez la
vérité
les organisations anticastristes de
miami veulent que le monde pense que
cuba ait à payer dangereux le seul et
unique moyen d'arrêter ces gens c'est en
infiltrant les organisations terroristes
en floride on a déjà des hommes sur
place un réseau efficace des espions
cubains à miami
et avec ces gens on ne sait pas très
bien où finit la lutte pour un cuba
libre et où commence le trafic de drogue
comprenez bien que votre sécurité
celle de votre époux cet office est de
tous les bancs de vous même
crois tu arriveras à pardonner
aujourd'hui
moment de vérité
enfin arrivé
[Musique]
rendre pas quelque chose comme ça c'est
vraiment à rien tu es fier de toi
[Applaudissements]
monsieur ce qui fabrique ces engins
doivent répondre de la mort de
vingt-quatre américain au cours des 12
derniers mois
finie tant que nous ne les trouveront
pas de nouveaux soldats américains
risquent de rentrer chez eux en morceaux
qui a envie de changer les choses
ça ne veut pas ça commence à bien
marcher pour moi
de quoi comme tu sens bien c'est lui à
carnival alors messieurs
quel est le plan j'essaie d'établir une
relation il est sérieux là et a envie de
s'amuser un peu
j'arrive pas de penser à ce jeune qu'on
a tué aujourd'hui je pense que c'est mal
oui tout à fait en tuant des leurres tu
sauves 10 des nôtres tu es en train de
me dire
que c'est mal
cet homme était une chance ne méritait
pas de mourir vie sans complice c'est
que tout ce qui se passe ici ça reste
dans la famille angoissé va chercher les
cibles tu crois qu'on va tirer dessus
et cette faire ce que tu penses être
juste mais le problème c'est que tu sais
pas encore ce qui est mal je veux tout
seul tu es seul tu sembles juste au
risque de mettre en danger parce que je
la ferme me donnez moi votre loyauté et
je vous garantis que chacun d'entre vous
aura l'occasion de devenir un guerrier
faire partie de l'histoire
un signal à 3
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
auj
[Musique]
yuuwaa go
au liban
[Musique]
le fond
la baisse
[Musique]
gregg cuthill
je fais ça pour les pourboires quatre
heures en vadrouille et tout ce que je
rigole c'est un vieux tickets resto
périmés pull qui pue le racisme ça
devrait vous aller comme un gant aux
livraisons habile belzile c'est pas ma
zone de livraison
c'est pour moi etes-vous déterminé à
investir dans votre future wii
réclamer ce qui vous est dû oui
etes-vous prêts quel qu'en soit le prix
à vous consacrer à satan oui
qui êtes vous je suis libraire de la
livreuse est ce que par hasard vous
seriez
encore vierge c'est un peu personnel ça
les vierges qui a le pouvoir de révéler
notre véritable potentiel
vous savez pas ce qui se trame ici ils
vont invoquer le dieux descend faire et
quand l'horloge naturellement il
ressuscitera à travers vous
où se trouve cette vierge comprend rien
à ce qui se passe
ma mère et ses potes ont l'intention
d'invoquer baphomet tu risques de finir
ligotés avec du fil barbelé un hôtel
quelle pervers vous savez pourquoi les
riches restent riches
vous restez faucher ils ont une bonne
assurance
voilà tant ils sont plus forts que tout
virgin pas de sacrifice des déchets
oibda complètement faible longue vie aux
puissants faut qu'on arrête de boire qui
veut vraiment les affronter sa voix
il est prêt pour moi cette case
là d'où je viens il ya des veilles de tu
vois tu me prends quelques jours je te
prend quelque chose la police est bien
suivre les mêmes règles et pas tu
pourrais me laisser prendre ta voiture
un soir cette fois qui fait ça un
nettoyage coin situé commence
aujourd'hui à l'école de ryes s'en
sortira très bien
papiers du véhicule 5,25
je vais parler sans détours d'après les
résultats de l'enquêté les policiers
impliqués ne feront l'objet d'aucune
poursuite
ils disent que si jay avait une arme et
avait accès à tous les dossiers
provisoire mon fils a été tué par le
même policier qui a tué le tiens
j'aimerais savoir ce que vous comptez
faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
nous
[Musique]
à
ce sera
[Musique]
s'il y en a trop
in fine à caractère
au mas de profession crash après midi le
syndicat d'eau
richard
[Musique]
de cuillé
m
[Musique]
l'espace
non aïe
les débris voler dans la volga
jusqu'à maintenant
[Musique]
cathy bossy
alors le maire va baisser
si j'étais lui
howard escrime plus tard face à la peta
mon accord
[Musique]